he obviously looked at my arm and said
to me we can make you about this size
the princess i was like whatever
i could have said to him about a 10-inch
one you know what i mean
[Music]
could you talk us through how you came
to lose your penis i was born in 1972 at
the age of around about six six and a
half
a winter's day in january we're throwing
snowballs at each other just mucking
about just kids being kids
and to this day i've always said that
all i remember is like before we
actually came to the main road i got the
last throw in before we were going to
cross the road to get to the other side
from there it was just a continuous
straight road to the school
somebody managed to push me into the
road
and
that
car was coming from the left who got
dragged and dragged under the cars of
the wheels of the car and dragged like
400 yards along the road
and
even the road was turning red because of
the blood
um that's all i really remember
could you describe to us what the main
injuries he sustained had been well my
penis was totally ripped off
and one of every man has two testicles
as you know
one of them was totally destroyed the
other one was managed managed to
with the impact it got pushed
up into my groin area
so were the doctors actively trying to
repair what happened to your body
i don't exactly remember what when they
built
a
object that allowed me to pee out of
when it was done but in the space of
about
i would say within the year they managed
to
build me something which
mimicked like a penis or a tube which
allowed me to go and have a pee you know
but when i say go and have a pee i would
only i could only sit down and have a
pee i couldn't stand up
but generally most of the time i was in
bed anyway because obviously all the
injuries i had how long would hospital
fall for recovery in and out i would say
about six years
in the lower hospital i only used to get
home at the weekends doctors did
everything they could to
not not save my penis because that was
already gone anyway but to save me
because as far as i'm led to believe i
was only given 12 hours to live i'm not
going to say that i looked i used to
look down and say that there's nothing
there because i can't even remember that
you know
but i know that
it was totally destroyed
do you think this
affected you socially
affected me everywhere because i'd never
i never got any psychologically any help
or anything you know i mean i just had
to deal with my issues myself i couldn't
like
shoulder to cry on i couldn't speak to
anybody you know lived in a community
where everybody knew everybody and
obviously
when they got to find out a bit about me
what happened to me
i just kept myself to sell myself to
myself and just basically
if anybody asked me any questions just
shied away or just
quickly
answered the question and just moved on
when i was about 37 38
i um
i must have went everywhere all over the
country i never went to europe but we're
all over the country and somewhere along
the line i went to a hospital in
edinburgh just outside edinburgh it was
a plastic surgeon
that i had seen
he actually
when i was about 42 he sent me a letter
through the post
he is now based in
edinburgh in firmly
he contacted me he said to me you came
to see me many many years ago
and
i'd like you to come and see me again
because i think
um i can do something for you now
i i was i was nervous i still i was
i was nervous but i was also excited at
the time as well so it was november
when i got my operation done
what does it actually involve to create
a bionic penis okay so basically
obviously compared to what i had before
and what i've got now it involves
a medical term which they call it the
radial artery full of phalloplasty which
involves they take skin from
your body
either your arm
or your back of your leg
and then obviously they take that skin
they've got whatever size they decide
they roll it up like a swiss roll and
construct a penis out of it
and then they put it basically
an implant in it which allows you to
have
sex
implant allows you to have addictions
involves a body a reservoir in my
stomach at the side here which it's got
saline in it and it's got two rods at
the front of my penis that's all gets
done like in first part was just the
penis and then obviously second part
this
the scrotum and then obviously the
glands they put the rods in and then
obviously the reservoir puts in the same
time did you have options like about
size i left out to him
he obviously looked at my arm and said
to me we can make you about this size
the penis i was like whatever you know i
mean yeah that's that's you leave that
to him i don't i never i've been a i
could have said to him about a 10 inch
one you know what i mean
but you just you know i mean you're just
grateful you're getting that opportunity
you know i mean
so was that nhs then yeah
luckily it was because a special
referral uh to get then from scotland to
edinburgh so he had in british london
had to get special referral and i
managed to get one funding from
the nhs they paid for it all seventy
thousand pound cost
that's what the cost tell who the cost
of that implant is
when you saw it how did you feel
um
yeah i felt i felt good because
obviously like i said compared to what i
had before and what i had it's totally
different you know yeah i felt like a
proper man
you know that's that's how
i was the most thing of the best thing i
was looking forward to was going
standing up i'm gonna be
they sent me home they sent to me that
you know now just go home and
give it two weeks and then basically
like because you still have to wait
until it kind of settles in
you know sometimes they can get rejected
as well you know these things happen so
two weeks i was just like
never
i knew it was there could feel it was
there i could feel my rods at the end of
my penis i can't feel this reservoir at
the side of my stomach
but i can feel something in my scrotum
and i can feel my roads but i just kind
of
wait i was just waited patiently for
that day to try and give it a go inflate
and deflate you know and
eventually you know that they did come
you know
it's
good
it was good yeah because obviously i got
it up but i couldn't get it done again
because i was getting like you know i
had wound myself up so much you know i
managed to get up and eventually you
know
it initially it was
it was easier to get up
but it was harder to get down because
you were getting i was getting myself
hot and flustered you know and um
eventually i just
i think i lay in my bed for the lake
about
and i ordered something you know up
and uh thinking what the hell am i going
to do you know it was like 11 o'clock at
night eventually so i just calmed myself
down and i started to
type to google it googled it and looked
at a video and eventually i just worked
it out you know
even though they showed me you know you
know but when you get you when they show
you just your minds thousands of
thousands of miles away you know
what did that do for your
self-confidence
well first of all i mean this should
answer your question i'm sitting here
talking to yous about it
then i couldn't he
i didn't want anybody to know you know i
just kept myself to myself
just shied away from everything now
totally opposite i don't go around
looking for partners just now because
i'm just
not that way i'm just not in that kind
of
zone or in that mood yet but if i do
potentially meet a partner you know i
will tell them i'll tell them exactly
what i've been through and
what i was like before and what i'm like
now and how it's changed my life from
the internet
i knew when pe or something was going to
come up i knew that you know
the girls were going to start you know i
wasn't allowed to get changed with them
in their changing room or anything
because even though like i say clitoris
i say that loosely
my clitoris is basically like a
small dick